13.
>> WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS.
FOX NEWS ALERT, PRESIDENTS BY A
FIVE TWEETING THAT MICK MULVANE
MULVANEY WILL SERVE AS HIS
ACTING CHIEF OF STAFF.
NOT PERMANENT CHIEF OF STAFF,
BUT MICK MULVANEY, MANY OF YOU
KNOW, HE WAS A CONGRESSMAN FROM
SOUTH CAROLINA.
WANT TO KNOW YOUR THOUGHTS ON
MICK MULVANEY, SEEING THEM
THROUGH?
>> THE BIG NEWS BEFORE THIS,
DANA, CHRIS CHRISTIE THE FORMER
GOVERNOR OF NEW JERSEY SAYING HE
WAS TAKING HIMSELF OUT.
WE'VE SEEN A SERIES OF PEOPLE
SAY, NO, I'M NOT GOING TO DO A
DIFFICULT JOB.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE COMING TWO
YEARS ARE GOING TO BE TURBULENT.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE MOVED
AWAY.
MICK MULVANEY IS REALLY TAKING
ONE FOR THE TEAM.
>> HE HAS THREE JOBS, JESSE.
>> BEING TRUMP CHIEF OF STAFF,
MY MOTHER RECOMMENDED THAT I DID
NOT DO THAT.
LIKE CHRIS CHRISTIE, I'LL BE
TAKING MYSELF OUT OF
CONSIDERATION.
LIKE I SAID BEFORE, IT'S ALL
ABOUT PERSONAL CHEMISTRY WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
IT LOOKS LIKE --
>> THEY HAVE A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP.
>> HE CAN STEER THE COURSE -- I
DO NOT KNOW HOW LONG IT'S GOING
TO TAKE TO GET A PERMANENT ONE.
MAYBE TWO WEEKS, A MONTH?
I DO NOT THINK A LOT OF THE
PEOPLES' NAMES THAT WERE BEING
DANDY ABOUT, CHRIS CHRISTIE AND
DAVID BOSSI, WERE ACTUALLY IN
SERIOUS CONSIDERATION.
>> THE PRESIDENT GOES INTO THE
WEEKEND WITH A LITTLE BIT OF
NEWS.
THAT STORY, WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
IT OFF THE PAGE.
>> I...
I'M NOT INTERESTED IN STAFFING
CHANGES AS MUCH AS I GET, I'M
SUPPOSED TO BE.
PEOPLE I WON'T MENTION,
SANTORUM, CLAIMING THEY ARE OUT
AND NOT OUT.
>> LIKE LOADING THEIR NAMES?
>> COME ON.
>> MLE?
>> TO POINT OUT FOR OUR VIEWERS,
THE ROLE OF AN ACTING POSITION,
THERE ARE LIMITS TO THAT.
THE FACT THAT THE PRESIDENT
APPOINTED HIM, CHIEF OF STAFF --
>> YOU CAN BE THERE IN A LONG
TIME.
>> IT COULD BE A WEEK AND A
MONTH.
IT CAN BE LONGER THAN THAT.
>> AFTER HE FOUND OUT HE WAS
CHIEF OF STAFF...
[LAUGHTER]
>> MICK MULVANEY HAD SAID THAT
HE WAS NOT INTERESTED IN THAT
POSITION.
THAT HE LIKED THE JOB HE HAD OR
EVEN CONSIDER A CABINET
POSITION, BUT A CHIEF OF STAFF
ROLE, I THINK HE'D MAKE A GOOD
CHIEF OF STAFF.
MAYBE HE'LL GET IN THERE AND THE
SITE IS PRETTY GOOD.
YOU ARE THE GATEKEEPER FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
>> THE MOST INTERESTING
POSSIBILITY HAD BEEN JARED
KUSHNER.
IF YOU BROUGHT IN JARED --
REMEMBER, WHAT HAPPENED IS THE
PREVIOUS CHIEF OF STAFF WAS SET
TO BE ON THE OUT WITH JARED AND
IVANKA.
BUT NOW I DON'T KNOW WHAT